all right good afternoon councillors and
uh welcome along to our november meeting
on this uh fine sunny google day
um
i will declare the meeting open and ask
for any apologies i think uh we have
uh one counselor is not here i think i'm
sure he's coming um so i
apologize for lateness from
nick grant
uh with somebody like to move that that
best
um accepted please that's our move
councilman fail drive a second look at
that um
thank you stuart
okay all those in favor please say aye
all right the motion is carried thank
you um so are there any um
conflicts of interest that need to be
declared that aren't part of the
standard conflicts that have been
declared today
um it
doesn't appear to be thank you
councillors
so we move on to the confirmation of
minutes and reports
and we have the confirmation of the
minutes of the ordinary meeting of
council hell on tuesday 12 october for
confirmation would somebody like to move
that be seen as a true and correct
record of that meeting please
it's councillor heisted secretary
councillor reed thank you
are there any alterations required to
that record
there aren't
i'll put that motion all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
um do we have any vision late business
that needs to be tabled um at this point
it's not
move on thank you
and it brings us to um
keeping of animals poultry and bees
bylaw
on page
pages 9 through 21.
uh we're gonna lead this discussion
i can you worship if you wish
thank you
this is a bylaw worship that we've had
in place for five years and is due for
review
the staff's
point of view is that the bylaw is
working well
and is an effective tool in regulating
the keeping of animals
in an urban environment so
the council does need to
turn its mind
and decide if it wishes to continue with
the bylaw and therefore go through a
public consultation process under the
local government act but our strong
recommendation is that the bylaws should
continue um and
what it does provide for is that you can
keep animals in an urban setting
but there are
rules and they must be adhered to
to ensure that they don't cause a
nuisance to other people who in the
urban area that
possibly would not normally expect to
see animals being kept but
as i say it's been an effective tool and
we recommend its continuance
okay okay councillors
this particular item is open for
discussion and or recommendation
uh council grant
uh thank you your worship um
just possibly a a question for steve
um this
i know this notice that this bylaw does
not apply to dogs or cats which which is
understandable but
just
of interest do we have a
bylaw which pertains to the number of
cats you're allowed to keep because i
know there was a case i believe in the
cargo where
a certain householder was keeping a very
large number of cats so do we do we have
that uh is that in another
part of our legislation or is it with
someone we don't have
rue your worship uh cats uh
get a pretty clear free run um so we
have obviously a adult controlled bylaw
uh this includes other and so eval
animals um
there has been over
probably decades thought and given to
uh regulating the control of cats uh
particularly around
both
the concentration of cats in one
dwelling which can give rise to concerns
about odor and
other unpleasant things
and of course their predatory nature and
the fact that some people will let cats
out at night and to run amok
but it's a big but
the government has not really moved on
that front
unlike in some jurisdictions within
australia i understand for example that
new south wales has actually a cat and
dog
act
regulates the the keeping of cats
but no
simple answers that we
cats uh
pretty much
enjoy a free license at the moment at
least in the gore district
thank you
thank you worship um so and i'll just
i'd like to move that uh
move the recommendation of that report
so just before um
we asked for a seconder
no council dixon and council high said
georgia hands up
well thank you worship um
i
endorse um
my concern about having a policy around
cats because they do carry some very
serious health issues like toxoplasmosis
and
they can't be contained
in anybody's section so they're like
along with um you have to keep rats and
mice an enclosed area or within your
property
and i know it's very difficult because
cats are a sensitive issue most likely
and i do like kids but i'm just
wondering for the future whether we
should be thinking about
some um some sort of policy on cats
because i believe it costs like
australians has been researched on six
billion dollars annually
for um people that are affected by by
cats
and they are they are a serious um issue
for
pregnant women
okay well thank you um
so i
what i understood steve to say is we
don't have any scope for that at this
point in time is that right
through your worship there's nothing uh
in the statute book that gives you a
sense of confidence and reliance that
you can use to
put out a
bylaw for example
on cats per se unlike say dog this is a
dog control act
but that's not to suggest that you can't
have some sort of bible but it would
need to be carefully assessed and you'd
have to again go through a process of
identifying
the problem that
what is the problem and what is the best
means by which to address that problem
which is which is good
um
law making or or policy process to go
through
but would need to do that and um
maybe you worship that it could be uh if
if there's interest in marx councils it
could be something that lends itself to
a perhaps a small working party of both
elected members and officers
to work through the issue and and also
see what else uh occurs in other
councils if anything in new zealand
okay good point thank you um
brett
your thanks tracy just a question for
for steve after three-year worship at
number three there's
um two specific exclusions veterinary
clinics pet shops i just see the gore
district council dog pounds not part of
the exclusions i just wonder if that's
worth reflecting on
and secondly the amp society land in
benin park but we don't refer to other
other bits of land owned by the council
such as charlton road but the passage of
time is it is it appropriate that they
reconsidered as part of the review steve
uh hear your worship yeah definitely um
yes i would like to i could certainly
sit down with uh
our
senior regulatory services officer and
just work out whether there should be
some um additions to those uh
particular locations that are not
applicable to the bylaw um yes
thank you
okay i think they've been good points
that are made
so that we want to we don't have a
second for the motion as such we want to
alter that motion with to any uh
specific recommendation
so do you want just given the discussion
we've had now do you want to just add to
that that a
working party be formed uh just to
confirm
the scope that council might have
that's yes your worship that sounds
agreeable to me just
alter the the the wording of that to say
um and a working party be formed
to look into
so the scope the scope of
the council with relation to control
cats
uh and regulation around cats as well as
um
second one that was just raised in about
um
it was bees in
areas that weren't specified is that
right fred
just the locations the exceptions under
under item three but i guess is this
going to hold up the consultation on the
review of the bile or is that a separate
piece of work like surely three could be
changed
um
before it goes out for consultation in
terms of locations and
the cat working party can
get going
so just in terms of process steve your
suggestion here
my suggestion in your worship is that
you
take it in a two-pronged approach so
that you
uh prove the bylaw subject to a
staff review of the exclusions
and clause 3 taking place for public
notification
and then separately that you establish a
cat working party or whatever you want
to call it
to look at the possibility of
introducing some
controls or to regulate
keeping of cats in the district
that's good
um so you're moving that dough
do i have a seconder for that
glennis thank you
is there any further discussion
on the recommendation that has been
added to
there's not i'll put that motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
thank you councillors
um right we'll move on to item six
and
uh we have a report from the chief
executives and the coms manager i don't
think about the conference manager with
us today
um with regard to equal street and a
petition that
came to council
recently
so um steve do you want to introduce
this particular
discussion
yes thanks your worship um this is
really the aftermath of the
controversial streets alive um
initiative that
officially ran for three months
from end of march to around about mid to
late june this year
and
there has been some some further
um
dialogue and engagement with the
community about uh
some remaining aspects of the street to
life program that should potentially be
retained in the future
in the meantime however
there has been a petition circulated by
those who
i guess are holding the council to its
word in regard to that it was a trial
and then once trial was completed
all trial aspects
um would be
removed
that said there were some things that
the council quite openly stated it
wanted to
to continue with
because it had received
very strong positive feedback and i
refer specifically to the eric street
furniture
and the roundabout at the intersection
of irk and fairfield street which also
found strong favor from those who were
surveyed
the bollards however on the corner of
the intersection of eccles and
main street are a different kettle of
fish
um
i think they with respect they are a bit
of a lightning rod for those who are
somewhat traumatized or bruised by the
streets life program
and see it as more akin to street works
that have no end point in sight
there's certainly
a proposal
uh for
a permanent arrangement which is
included in the attachments
to have a no right turn at the equals
main street intercession i think your
worship the key point here is to
to signify to the public at large that
any
motion there or resolution to remove the
bollards is not necessarily an
acceptance that there's not going to be
no right turn at the corner of
echos and main street
what you are doing is saying
well yeah they the trial is over uh and
that
the bollards if you do approve their
removal
on the basis that it's likely that there
will be a permanent
infrastructure introduction to
facilitate a orderly
and smooth
transition for no right turn at the
intersection of vehicles and mainstream
so the report has been prepared on that
basis that it's about the removal of
these temporary facilities
not
necessarily agreeing that there will
never be no right turn at equals in main
street
um
so that's and mr standard is here and
can
we may be able to be in a better
position than i am
to
commentate on the prospects of waka
katahi or nzta funding
to
bring about the permanent provision of a
no right turn that would
be
in sync with the type of um
modern improvements that we want to see
as opposed to the temporary
option we have at the moment
okay thank you
so peter do you want to make some
comment now
just on my pointer raised about the
funding
there is funding that is actually coming
on stream with the second row of um
uh trance of innovative streets
and part of that has actually been
promised to be
um
turning some of the positive aspects of
this um innovative streets
into permanent permanent fixtures
but
the detail of that hasn't actually been
released as yet so that's what i'm
holding out for that and also that if we
did something on equal street it would
require some sort of consenting from the
local uh ncta representatives so that
would help be something we work through
necessarily on the state highway they
would actually be doing any funding any
of the
changes themselves so once again there's
always sort of discussions to be had but
this is to get to a point where
uh community we're actually happy with
no right turn there and having some
demonstration of what that looked like
uh albeit it may be misinterpreted but
um certainly be intense to leave there
until there's some decision made and
this is what we are here today with
thank you yeah certainly the the
bollards have been um
a rallying point for people who were
really concerned about not just that
that particular item of um change but
also the whole sum
so to get um that removed and worked
towards some sort of permanent
operation of the street would be good in
my mind but open for
councillors discussion
and or our recommendation
and we have a recommendation on page 24.
so council dixon you've got your hand up
then councilman
oh thank you worship
um
i'm i'm just wondering what the
difference is between likes of norton
western earl and midway streets where
you have
right turning
um and also if we are actually going to
ignore the petition where 500 people
actually want the right turn out of
equal street
this i thought this
was discussed at our last meeting and
that the courtesy crossings were to go
and i see the courtesy crossings are
still in place
um and i'm i'm just wondering where all
this
what has happened to
to the committee that was going to
take care of getting removing all of
this infrastructure
[Music]
some good questions there linus um so
richard do you want to make some
comments on that one and then counselor
davis nicki
yeah and i think he was
um
okay firstly i'm going to sound like a
bit of a stuck record um
but we obviously have a bit of credit to
comms and and their roading crew
on getting us to this point
um i think there is
um
some differing or difference in opinion
or different
um sort of aspects that we've been
presented with today
regarding
what we're actually looking at um
particularly in well we're talking about
the echo street main street intersection
now
i'm probably going to throw a spanner
amongst the works here because
um with due cognizance to the review
group
and obviously the survey and partition
and also note in our report
um that it really should be the
council's agree to a permanent solution
here
um i think that we should be
uh looking at this partition and for
those who have actually uh followed the
survey results um and also the uh
the various review groups
and
obviously the partition that has come in
um
a closer scrutiny of that partition for
those who haven't gone through it
thoroughly there's actually um 60
different
street or ratepayers from different
streets
um have actually signed that partition i
know there is some discussion around how
it was um
labelled but
for those who have been uh bearing a lot
of the phone calls
from
ratepayers and uh road users will
understand that a lot of it was
referenced to the main street equal
street
um situation so i think that today
if we look at that recommendation that
we should actually be reinstating that
right turn
at present i don't think
um i don't think
we should actually be uh giving that
indication
to install that right turn um and i'll
come back to the second issue that leads
with that
i know that our roading managers
indicated we've got a 54 seal increase
on state highway
there
that actually continues right up to
where
a lot of people talk about the
roundabout and the distance they have to
travel back through which is some 750
meters
just back into town or they take the um
variant route
i think that if we are going to look at
uh
a recommendation
that is outlined that we are
um
[Music]
improving or want a permanent
infrastructure there there needs to be a
small small amount of work done on that
and i believe the right turn needs to go
back into there the bollards need to be
removed and the bollards and the other
situations need to be removed
and we need to see how much traffic's
actually turning right there
how much traffic was going on to the
state highway there because we didn't
get any measurement or statistics to
indicate how much we were putting into
the traffic flow
remembering
if we push them north onto bowler ave
they come down through a stop sign and
they make the same right turn again
onto a same stretch of road
which is only further north
so the traffic flow won't change from
from that point to that point
um
the second issue is
uh obviously
the roading manager needs to make
operational decisions so we need to be
able to support him in that but we've
opened this up
to a community and
a consultation process
and i think that we need to as a council
recognise that 500 names have come into
the council
in an acceptable manner
in relation to
um a community issue and i know that
from my own personal point of view
friends and family have indicated that
they wish that to remain
but we also have a large majority of
signatures that have been brought to our
council
that indicate that they don't want it to
remain so um
in the comment or correct community
process
we probably need to recognize that
and it has to be uh
if we look talking about this
intersection today
the council will either yes or no
um recommend that
we reinstate the right turn
and that our roading manager then goes
back
uh does that and then comes back with
the further information
that substantiates why that should go in
um because we still haven't got the
statistics or the uh information there
and peter may be able to help us with
that i know that he's probably uh
thinking um you know
is the
dog being well wagged by the tail but
the situation we are sitting in is
consultation
and in today's environment particularly
as council
we know what it's like to be on the
receiving end of um
a
non-consultatory process
particularly if we reviewed it with the
three-wooders reform
so we should stand up and actually
accept that these guys have gone out and
done this
and have a bit of a look at it um i have
gone through the surveys i have gone
through the uh the review your
information uh that's probably where i
would stand on the subject
there's been a lot of work done by the
team i know that uh there's some great
stuff comes out of it
we've got the roundabouts we've got eric
street and i know peter's got some other
designs and uh matters that that
will progress streets alive is finished
we're moving on to the next stage let's
just tidy up a few of these issues if we
need to go further with that
infrastructure there i think it's a
separate issue again
and then at the present we remove it
back to what it originally was um and
then start their game plan from there
thank you thank you richard and and i
guess um
you've um
you've spoken well uh about the
particular issue and your feelings on
the issue and the community view and
separating those two points and i guess
probably i'm in a similar camp to that
personally i like the no right turn
but i recognise that a lot of people
have said this is
an imposition to us so we need to take
notice of that
but i know that i use um
civic um
uh quite a lot and trying to do a right
turn across the main road at the end of
that is a nightmare and
and i recall using echo street in a
similar way and finding the same thing
so i'll be interested to see what the
stats show in terms of who actually uses
it for a right turn and and how many
people are there
but we do need to recognize our petition
and
the validity of that
um so
look i think we're we're heading down
the right track but council davis and
council grant
you thank you worship i think we're
opening ourselves up for a lot of grief
if we take them all out
open up to a right turn and then in the
future
put in a no right turn
where people can't turn right out of
there i think you're sitting council up
for um
quite a bit of grief on this one so i
think we should we need to just make a
decision on whether we
keep with no right turn at all or
whether we reinstate the right turn i
don't think we should be removing it and
then putting a right turn in later
that's going to cause
a lot of
backlash from the community i believe
and you've got 530 something people
already that have said we want the right
turn reinstated so you go you go taking
out bollards and everything
open it up let you let people turn right
and then next year sometime you go and
put
all the bollards in and remove it again
so i that's my view i think you go one
way or the other i don't think you
should be
um
confused in the public
well i think the the points you make and
nikki are good ones
um but i guess we don't
don't
we shouldn't lose sight of the fact that
there is uh while we have 500 signatures
uh wanting a closure of the right and my
right turn option
and prepared to go with that there were
quite a few other views out there as
well so
we need to um get rid of the bollards as
they currently stand
and then as councilor mcfarland said do
some testing do some measuring and just
see what the particular issues are it is
a busy break and it's going to become
busier if we
allow the right turn there as well so we
just need to bear in mind that if we do
take those away today
the
traffic flow will change and we should
always be monitoring that it's been
interesting through this whole process
of streets alive to see that
and and since streets alive has changed
substantially
the increase in traffic on main street
has been substantial
and nobody's really been able to give me
a satisfactory answer as to why that
increase on main street has happened but
it has so we need to take that into
account as well but i recognize the
points that you make uh councillor davis
who don't want to be seen to be
flip-flopping on this one but we need to
have some stats behind the decisions
that we're going to make sorry
councillor graham
thank you worship um
i'm i was part of the
uh committee uh that was for the small
committee that was formed after streets
alive and and to be honest streets of
life were supposed to be over and done
with
and at the end of it and and that was it
basically and there were a few things to
tidy up
but i i didn't know anything about this
the uh survey going up whether i missed
a meeting or wasn't told about it but
all of a sudden the surveys come out and
now we've got a report written and i
didn't even know there was a petition
going around so how did that all come
about was it was done through
comms going by out by themselves or was
it directed by the chair of that small
committee or what was the story because
and this is a question that councillor
dixon just raised a few
few councillors ago so how do we get to
this stage
um
as far as the recommendation yeah well
that would be a good one to answer for a
start thanks
well i think as far as competition goes
um that's quite separate from the
council and there's been a group of
concerned citizens have promoted that
and that that's fine in terms of uh
surveying my understanding is that's
just a summary of the comments that have
been made on our let's talk platform
which counts
[Music]
you worship just just in regard to that
the um the question was uh to answer
councillor grant's question it did go
through our comms manager and it was
also discussed with um peter standring
i'm pretty sure the council might have
been there we just
wanted specific information how we could
obtain
some specific information regarding the
equals of main street because the
one of the complaints from the community
was they never got a chance to comment
on it in the first two surveys and i
think that's where that uh derived from
and i think the catalyst for them
or the groups or the people that were
involved from there was that they
thought they had to put their signatures
again
or put together the group to come back
to indicate that they uh had had that
there
um and discussion with them um but there
was queries in regard to the question
they have on the top of the partition
i'm not sure you've been through it read
that question it's listed in the notes
there
but
there's a number of those things that
were being stated and there had been
sorted by the writing manager anyway so
sorry worship i was just going to answer
that
for you
okay so thanks for that well i i
actually uh
i support um
the feelings of counsellor dixon i
believe we should actually and and
councilman fail um we should take the
bottles away um as you've got 500 people
that have written
written their name to it
take them away open it up again and then
as peter standing has suggested we leave
well we can't we don't own that section
of road anyway so it's going to have to
go through nzta to or
to get sued so
it's really a no-brainer as far as i'm
going to say
thanks
counselor dixon
thank you worship um another issue i
think that was raised and i think it's
rather
um it's a good to bring up now as well
is the giveaway sign on echo street and
elsie street
i just don't know why that hasn't been
removed because
it just seems that the major flow of
traffic is down echo street
and the minor flow is coming out of elsi
street
and they're usually turning right or
left they're not going straight through
i've seen one or two people
not slowing down there at all thinking
they have um right away
which is could cause an accident too i'm
wondering why that hasn't been removed
i'll get some comment from the reading
manager but i know myself as someone
that uses echo street regularly um that
certainly it's a lot slower down there
and um there's been quite a bit of
appreciation by the residents of that
street with the slowness certainly it's
a change and it's a change we have to
get a hit around and and
and i i know some people struggle with
but perhaps peter if you could talk
about
what the plans are there
uh certainly free self-worship um
i um to answer that echo street was
specifically brought up in uh some of
our initial community
meetings is a street of uh
speed
far too busy congestion
so it was a targeted stream to actually
try to sort out so two of the
two ways of sorting that out is actually
stop people turning right into state
highways so people won't take that
option they'll go further and uh go down
crombie street and i believe that is
where people are directed
rather than all out through bubble wrap
i think if you're working about in a
city in a town
you'll go away but generally people in
the residential area they like to go
down cranberry street now so i think we
have done
a fair amount of actually redirecting
traffic down that way crombie street out
on state highway for a roundabout which
is more logical
so take them out away so the speed down
echo street which was
uh well talked about
um this is what the sensation does it
brings people to a stop and your vehicle
then they but the predominance of
traffic usually has the right of way but
in this case
the point we're trying to make is just
trying to slow vehicles down
so
once again trying to talk to the public
talking to people who have businesses
down that way and they are seeing a
noticeable change in the speed down that
street and being a lot safer
especially when you have kids hospital
people
you've got preschools all mixing in
those areas crossing over having slower
speed
uh environment certainly helps it goes a
long way for young pre-safety
so um
brahman i think you were part of the
working party too do you want to make
any comment
on these particular issues we're
discussing now
um um i thank you worship um
completely the echo street one i know
that the residents there have
appreciated the slowness of the traffic
i think that's a good one and it's just
a matter of people becoming more used to
the traffic flow um particularly when
you've got as peter said the medical
center the hospital um and there's a lot
of traffic part on the side of the road
and you've also got the
people crossing that road and i've
noticed with the slower traffic
they're actually much easier to spot and
they can spot cars as well much easier
equal street court turning south
i live on crombie um i use the
roundabout at the end of my street
um but i think given that there's also a
facility there the playground for the
for the young ones um
that no right turn option is possibly a
good one um i'm in favor of the no right
turn option and a lot of people who
didn't sign the petition but actually
took part on the let's talk
um
arena uh were actually quite positive
about it
so i think you've got a 50 50 call on
that one um
i think we just need to be uh
a little bit more cautious about jumping
in and saying it's not going to happen i
i think we need to have that um
ability to turn around and say yes we've
got numbers and stats but also
if we're going to do that i'd like to
know if we could possibly
um
have some stats of the number of traffic
at the crombie street roundabout too
just so we can um see where that flow is
whether more people are using
it but yeah that's my opinion i'm quite
happy to see the right turn um go i
think
it's just an accident waiting to happen
so um
councillor heisted then councillor
bulger
you thank you just some of the feedback
i've had regarding the echo street
giveaway is the confusion we've set up a
number of small roundabouts around town
which people are used to but when they
travel down echo street they encounter a
giveaway where different rules apply
i'm just wondering peter has any
consideration been to perhaps a
roundabout on it echo street
um
and you know
what's a giveaway now so it's consistent
with the rest of our modifications
um for your worship look most definitely
i am
we have moved on from a street slide but
was always going to inform
a package of work
improvements going forward
and so that active modes program ford
rose program will be coming to council
for your look over but certainly one of
the recommendations will be to people
like roundabouts they've got just a
roundabouts having around about an equal
street there makes a lot of sense
so
as far as the right turn to go itself
people should not be profiting to see
the line and turn this out particularly
when they've got a uh around about
a short distance so it's it's
you know it's dangerous
whether
it's inconvenient or people have a
preference that they want to do that
it's
dangerous i don't um
however you describe it it's dangerous
it always will be dangerous it's not the
thing to do it's the wrong thing that we
should be doing so i'm in favor of not
having the right to but peter's just
raised the point of uh
possibility perhaps of a roundabout that
makes sense i've got a question for you
for peter uh is there any crash
statistics
for that echo street
stay high everyone in the section
uh for your worship no look i haven't
got those statistics
um i can
address uh one of your concerns earlier
uh you wish
about the increase in traffic this is
statistics that came from uh waka katahu
themselves
and this is the outskirt of towns that's
outside of the area of influence of
streets alive
and they actually showed a 50 increase
from because they last year through to
june this year
of traffic that was flowing
i can't explain it they can't but the
only thing i could possibly put to it is
that with matara valley there where
there's more traffic coming through town
because of that
[Music]
yeah maybe
living in the tower i don't know coming
back and forth through town but
that's definitely an account that was
actually made by the agency themselves
uh councillor phillips then councilman
thank you worship i just got a question
for peter
so did you do any monitoring while the
bollards were up
on echoes state highway one
in any monitoring like
the traffic slow coming out
going out
as far as we had particularly accounts
um on those roads i can't
i have to actually sort of take them out
to recall them
to children
um monitoring of the
no right turn how we're going to set out
now with the roundabout with um bollards
is that what you're questioning
correct
so did you do any traffic flows while it
was while it's completely set up because
my concern is that uh you know i'm in
favor of keeping that no right turn but
if we haven't got any monitoring done
how can we justify leaving it there and
saying that this is the safety
issue
if there hasn't been any monitoring
saying that
there's
the safety issue of the right-hand turn
is is decreased
and you're traveling only another 600
meters to the roundabout and then back
again
like there is other streets that you
turn down that you can cross over the
over the state highway one and i'm just
bit concerned that we've never done any
monitoring
um look we have actually done
observations of how it is flowing one of
the concerning things we came up with
was a lot of people use that
intersection as a as a turnaround
we had people turning into echo street
and
being lost
we had to do a u-turn and go back down
the main street they were generally
using it as a
turnaround in the intersection
which complicates it all as well which
is another
concern with people using it in that
fashion and you've got right turning
traffic you've got an increase in
traffic but no longer there wasn't any
sort of general um
it was a contributing factor the safety
at bad intersection but the flow of
traffic up and down echo street was
the main
outcome we were looking for here and yes
we did have traffic accounts which was
supportive of a decrease in traffic
because i do know that um three words i
do know that uh the car dealer across
the road
is uh it was extremely grateful about
what's happened
uh
and with the no right-hand turn because
it makes his business a lot safer
because he hasn't got traffic coming out
almost straight at straight out of his
business to turn right
and
he only then knows about the traffic
that's coming straight from the from the
north to south and he doesn't have to
worry about the cross traffic
and you know and it's
a good point for him
and businesses along that street
okay
thank you um
richard did you want to make a comment
yes uh just just worship through uh to
peter there um we we've also had a huge
increase in traffic like it's larger
than the increase south of the township
traveling north through railway espana
which we're also having i think was 83
or 82 increase there
so there is traffic travelling somewhere
through our town and and uh
and making our roads busy busier um
and i think that that does form basis
for
for what we're actually looking at here
today where which is why i sort of
indicating that if we have got traffic
flows increasing um and as neville
councillor phillips has said we do need
to um have some sort of
statistic or
some some stat to base ourselves on so
we're going back there
i'd also just like to reiterate what i
said before that
with the partition and having worked
with this working group that um
we have to be careful that we don't see
the president for roading changes just
and i think council davis
said it as well like we start tampering
with things and changing um at this
level that the voting manager is able to
make um adjustments and plans and
different matters it's probably because
of the partition that this has been
brought into the public eye
and we have quite a large community
commentary regarding it i do
uh stick with the recommendation in
response to councillor uh
bulger
generally if you make a right-hand
corner
turn off any intersection you will cross
the center line so um
there's not much you can change about
that in life if you're driving a motor
vehicle you will go across the center
life unless you've got a different way
of driving so
um
but
with the recommendation uh i believe
that uh
put it forward that we stick with the
first three uh three recommendations the
reports received the community feedback
uh that the orange bollards and the
interceptors are removed
but also that we reinstate that right
turn
south
whether we want to reword
the intention from our roading manager
to review
that intersection later
[Music]
that's probably the debatable point
thank you um
look i think that the points have been
well made um and as i said before
personally
i'd favor a no right turn however
we do need to recognize
500 people
and there is an obligation on council to
to do that
but we shouldn't lose sight of the fact
that there is a changing and evolving
situation on main street and as i think
peter and richard have both said the
volume of traffic that is both the ends
of our town is increasing substantially
i don't really understand why that is um
but as the traffic increase goes up then
the risk goes up um and particularly
when you mix it with children and and
playgrounds and and that sort of thing
um we also need to remember that equal
street itself is a
like it's it becomes a very busy street
and it does have
the doctor's
surgery right on it and also the turn
off to the hospital there is quite a
number of people crossing the road
on eagle street so having that slow is
is particularly good i believe
i know it may inconvenience some people
but certainly it conveniences other
people who are trying to
the street to get to a medical
consultation
um brett you've got your hand up
yes sorry just quickly erosion just a
question to peter we'll talk about
removing orange bollards from echo
street what about the rest of them
around town the bottom of broughton
street
um i understood it was an orderly
removal of
the activations
when are we going to see them go
there's one on
robertson street just to scatter around
town i think it's it's time to
to see those orange bollards that are
irritating people
off our streets
i don't know if other councils agree
with it
for free worship um they have been put
in there for a purpose to
a lot of uh
activations still have
that's you still have some um a lot of
um
other but some pieces out on the street
still so they could all be taken and the
reason we've left them there is until we
can actually find pathway to permanency
i suppose we've actually sort of left
them a lot of the crossings albeit
the pots and planters have been taken
and the crossings are still there
essentially and people are using them we
are seeing that happening so
with the government policy statement
governing a lot of what i do uh it's
upon me to actually be putting to
council that we do need to make town
uh friendlier to the active modes so i
would be in this position anyway as far
as pushing a program of work to you
about active modes at about crossings
what streets alive has allowed us to do
is to trial in different areas
it was lost in the form that we put it
out there we put it out in planters
people sort of missed that but the
function itself i think has actually
been well received by an element of the
community some people i acknowledge have
actually found that frustrating but it
was more about actually
being there for people who who opt to
get around active modes walking and
writing and we have heard a lot of
people who have actually found it a lot
easier for that so i'd be here in this
position to be bringing this program to
you anyway
what those
bollards and that out there are still
representing is where we could
potentially be putting this stuff so
look
i could be taking that stuff in tomorrow
but i would be proposing in my program
of work at the bottom of broward street
there there we have an island coming
around redirecting traffic that reduces
helps reduce speed at the end there so
that would be one of my suggestions a
number of the areas are going to have
crossings we've got our roundabouts
still in place and we've got thresholds
at the end of rose brown street robinson
street that are still actually doing a
good job as far as
reducing traffic as people entering into
a certain zone
so my representative of probably a
program and i'd be looking to put to
council but
uh if it's a wish of the council well of
the council these can be taken on
tomorrow yeah peter i understand it's
the orange bollards that seem to be
you know they don't seem to represent
what you're trying to achieve it's not
perceived as what the end result would
be and i think they detract from
the solution and i think equal street's
a good example
the solution you put forward the
permanent solution is great and would
fly but the orange bollards has created
a
an ill feeling and i think you've got
the same issue but the orange bollards
are my
my issue and i think if you're going to
measure what's happened to the main
street i think the bottom of brown
street's probably driving traffic onto
the main street that would normally go
that way whether that's right or wrong
but that's where the traffic possibly
has been going so
i i just think
for me orange bollards should should be
removed and i think the community would
get a sense of
we have fully deactivated
that uh
that uh word streets alive well the two
were at streets a lot
[Music]
okay councillors um you've got a
decision to make uh you've got some
recommendations that have been laid out
um
it sounds like there needs to be some
moderation to those recommendations
so i'm open for
a new recommendation
for an alteration to the to the current
ones
so there is no change so which time
no
i think our recommendation
there should be amendment there in
regard to the fourth one i'd like to put
forward amendment
um
that we sorry the third one reinstate
the right turn south
immediately that the orange bollards are
removed
okay
you're worshiping this
by way of explanation that was always
the intent um so the into the
recommendation was that the right the
bollards be removed and the
uh right turn
be allowed pending
until such time as a more permanent
arrangement takes
place
so if a permanent arrangement was to
take place what would be the process
there peter in terms of coming to the
council for that discussion
um
putting a program of work our credit to
council to get your uh approval for the
work that's to be done um the funding um
issue as well i have
once again waiting for a second round of
funding to come through from ncta so
i am looking to
see if they have been 90 some funding
there we can take advantage of so
firstly is to get the designs done get
them into council for for approval
but in the meantime and things can
actually be i can withdraw more from
roads as far as the followers
um i'm not getting the feedback possibly
from the public as you you may be
um about how inconvenient my crossings
are i i do talk to the heavy traffic
people
and they can not give me that same sort
of feedback that they're becoming an
issue they are still doing a job and
like at the end of brown street or
um a lower cube
was a bit different to a row of um
orange
there may be some misrepresenting there
well i guess there's
certainly alternative views from
councillors on this particular issue but
i guess what counselors overall are
wanting to hear peter is that if those
orange collars are removed uh as per the
recommendation that there won't be
anything go back in there without it
come to council first
correct
okay
right so we've got um
council bulger council grant and council
davis
if that's the intention that the
bollards are removed and it's put back
the way it was and the the right hand
turned south
is reinstated
but a more permanent solution is being
considered to look for we've just got to
make sure that we
inform people
that it still could be a change and we
we still haven't finished
finding a solution for that intersection
uh
i'm comfortable with with the right hand
with the ball i've been removed um but
we've got to tell people that this may
not be the end of it we it is a
dangerous intersection and
in
notwithstanding the
the petition we've got a responsibility
to see if we can find a safer way
and if that makes us unpopular so be it
so i'll support the the um
the recommendation with its uh amendment
but i just want to see the public
informed that there could well be some
more work done in that section
that's the grant
yeah i totally agree with councillor
bulger there but i disagree with
councillor heisted um
as far as removing all bollards um
we need to to be honest this this report
we've actually gone way outside of what
this report was
this is all about equal street
intersection and we're we're actually
bringing up streets alive again which we
probably shouldn't be even entering into
but
we have done so so
um i'm going to have my say on the
bollards as far as removing them all
i've talked to two school teachers or
one principal at a school um where the
bollocks and he said he's saying to me
hurry up and put something permanent
here these bollards are the best thing
since sliced bread you took out the uh
we took out the planters for the simple
fact that the public didn't like the
planters and fair enough uh they didn't
look that great but those bollards and
ice i use an intersection every day or
twice three times a day sometimes
that intersection is extremely safe
because the bollards are sitting in the
middle of the road until peter gets
something around them other than the
bollards i agree with council high state
they are ugly but
they need to stay around especially
around the schools it slows the traffic
coming out of saint peter's driveway
when they're turning onto robinson
street slows the right down and
basically at the end of the day uh those
ones should stay there but i'll support
uh councillor
uh mcfaul and councillor bulgers um and
i'll second this uh councilman fails
recommendation
so
just so i'm clear did you use working
invention councilman
you did
uh yeah i i think probably uh the ceos
probably filled in a gap for me there on
the third paragraph just to make sure
that we reinstate that right right turn
south
um
because that will make sense should we
uh because the third recommendation as a
council note the intention to install
permanent so it's not actually we are
so i'm quite happy with that
recommendation
you're moving just so we're all clear uh
you're moving the recommendation on page
24.
yes
that the orange bollards at the
intersection of eccles and main street
be removed immediately reinstating the
right turn south this the four words
need to be
included reinstate right turn south okay
so you will see me but yeah you're
signing that though
yeah thank you okay so we've got our
hands up from council davis council
dixon and councillor heisted um i have a
discussion from then i think we've had
enough discussion on this once that has
gone on and or put that in motion so
council davis and council dixon council
heisted
thank you worship i think if
even though we've moved outside the
scope of this report for the other
bollards i think if the other bollards
are there
they're there for a safety reason and i
think they should stay until peter has
another solution for
that particular spot so i'm in favor of
keeping the other bollards around town
and until peter comes up with a plan
um i think with removing the um right
turn so allowing the right turn again at
eagle street we have to be clear with
the public
really really clear this so i agree with
councillor bulger they have to
understand that this could change
because otherwise they're going to
accuse the council of flip-flopping of
um going back and forth and not being
able to make a decision so
the public have to be informed that
we're going to open it up again but
there is a caveat around that that we
may well have to reinstate a no right
turn so as long as that's put out with
everything else i'm comfortable
okay thank you councillor heisted
oh sorry councillor dixon and council
isd
thank you worship i have a lot of
feedback from the public and they really
dislike those orange bollards and i'm
just a question for you peter how soon
could you get something permanent in the
air and take them away because they are
quite
distracting and they do look like road
works
free worship uh it really does come down
to getting that program together being
having it okay by the
council the community and getting the
funding that's going to support that so
this construction period is actually
sort of getting chewed up pretty fast
it's probably more likely going to be
uh and maybe mid-season might even be
you know into june july
but before we can actually get something
going there
i'd like to think earlier but it's just
the process we need to go through
thank you
councillor heisted
yeah thank you russia uh look i think
the discussion has got off the scope of
the report but this is the first
opportunity councils have had
to discuss it
when i believe the council resolved a
number of months ago to urgently
deactivate streets alive in response to
public feedback and a working party was
formed to manage the deactivation
what we seem to have near now is some
some winners and losers being being
selected it's not deactivation of
streets alive so i would just like the
working party i haven't got the
recommendation in front of me to refer
to and i
i could possibly be inaccurate but my
understanding was streets of life was
being withdrawn
and we're saying but we like orange
bollards and we like this and we like
that
not very clear
okay so look i think we've had enough
discussion on this we have a clear
recommendation which is there's actually
the original recommendation with the
slide addition to
recommendation three
and just for
my information the addition
of what words go in there
after immediately
reinstating a right turn to worship
right so reinstating or writing
okay uh the root motion's been moved and
seconded um i'm going to put that motion
all those in favor for this hour
against
just i need to count those numbers
please those in favor please right hand
up
one two three four five and six against
one two three okay so the motion is
carried thank you um
thank you councillors uh
this um these are the
the issues that we have been elected to
um
to make the right fools on um as a
council
and
and while a lot of the calls we make
are easy ones uh sometimes the easy ones
are not always the right thing to do but
we are here to do the right thing
and i know i believe that if we take our
time to work through
some of the changes that have been
proposed and trialled through the
streets low and put them in the right
form
not only will they
provide us with a safer environment
but they will be accepted and embraced
by by the community maybe not today or
tomorrow uh but as time goes on
so peter you've got your hand up
um
where should i
can i ask that we can
at least for me two weeks or a week to
get this done because i'm keeping true
to
councillor phillips requests about
getting some good information it would
be good to have a trip encounters on
um echo street a week before we
open it up and then we'll see what
happens afterwards we can recount in a
month's time but if you gave me a week
or two weeks at least i can get that
done and i've got some information to
run off
i feel comfortable with that is there
any council to have an objection
just as soon as practicable
okay thank you so we'll move on then to
um
item seven and alternative location for
the
war dog pound
uh and we have a
report here from the administration
officer uh i'm just not sure who's going
to be speaking to this one is that you
knew
uh yes sure sure okay do you want to
lead us into this discussion
um
the
original
pound was going to be located at the ox
station ponds um you'll remember we had
a robust discussion several months ago
when we gave an update on the
positioning of the pound
the
resource consent stage meant that we had
to get
preferably permission off a neighbour
because of the
any building housing animals within 15
metres of a boundary
we were working through that process but
suddenly the neighbor did a complete
u-turn
um
so
because of that and i understand there
has been some discussion
via the council
we i've looked at the different
localities of what land that is already
owned by the council and basically this
is the only other alternative uh to be
suitable uh for that
so i put the report as such
to the council
thank you uh thank you neil uh and the
report is is open um
full discussion just uh uh and i thank
you for the information you've put here
it's um
it's a good and informative
report just a question around what
potential uses other than a dog pound
that land might be
put to
as time goes on have
have the district plan
group um
considered any particular options there
that uh that may impede uh the use of a
this particular area for
a pound yeah i want to make any comment
there steve or cliff
i'll have a stab at it we haven't really
uh
in our deliberations considered
uh the activities at the
airport at this stage but what i do
notice is peter kim thorne owns business
there
and leases um the area substantially off
of council's comfortable
i do know that he's had a long-standing
interest in the activity
at the airport i know there was some
thought in the past of
potential to have private hangars and
things like that but um
i would think at this stage initially
i'd be happy to take my lead from uh
peter kinford and bradley york because
they are essentially though the people
who are
you know in residence on leasing if you
like
um
i have to say i it's just unfortunate
that our neighbor uh the oxidation pond
doesn't seem to be particularly council
friendly
that disappoints me um
i just have to put that out there i'm
sorry
so just at this stage i don't think
there's any particular impediment to the
dog peon going down there
okay thank you
and you're speaking in your
role as a playing group um steve do you
want to make any comment before i open
it up for discussion
yeah thanks worship i think um i know
from i did speak to
our consultants the property group about
this upcoming item uh earlier this
afternoon in my regular catch-up
and they actually thought it was a
planning sense was a really good idea
against i mean planes and dogs they both
can make noise so
um and i do like the idea that's outside
the urban boundaries i do like the idea
that it's
a bit more central to both you know gore
and matera not just domingor
and to be honest i can congratulate neil
because sometimes when you've
you've been around a while you don't
really see the opportunities that are
there and
this is land that we're not really doing
much with and
i just
can see that we won't
get too many issues in relation to
the movements to the property the dog's
barking it seems to me to be a pretty
good location all round
okay thank you so nicky you've got your
hand up yes you wish it
really good outcome neil i'll
congratulate you on um pursuing this
after your initial efforts were
scuppered um and i think
maybe the landowner has done us a favor
at the oxidation ponds in the long term
i think this is a really good
alternative
and i think provided the security of it
and we can
have a fairly secure pound um
is good and the the current leases of
the
gore airport are
comfortable then i'm very happy i think
this is a very good solution so
it's off to you
thank you council davis through your
worship um in regards to the peter
kempthorne and bradley york
they hold the positions of vice
president chairman and uh sorry
secretary treasurer
um they're looking at the long term that
we will have their extra lighting and
some form of security
in and they can see a beneficial for
both parties
in the long run for that area
okay thank you
so
john glennis and then neville
no no it's good good outcome um being a
sheep farmer dog pounds and dogs
do not go together with a sheep farmer
and i think that's some of the problem
you've had
and also with the
um we had
the same problem with a stray dog up
here even if you have a dog barking on
your boundary
your blaming sheep will move right
across the other side of the paddock a
dairy cow will come and probably
find out what's going on so it's quite a
good place to have it down at the
airport and also with the um three
waters thing going ahead we may not have
as much control over that area in the
future and i think it's a good outcome
meal and um
a good goodbye move forward i think
thank you
thank you worship um just a question for
you um steve i'm wondering if there was
a change in zoning at any stage whether
it could
um be an impediment having a dog pound
there
uh through your worship not if there's a
change in zoning because once you're
lawfully established you have existing
use rights and you can continue
in that same vein for an indefinite
period
okay thank you so um
neville thank you worship i just got a
question to neil i've seen your report
about the infrastructure and the water
i'm just a bit concerned about uh it's
non
it's non-portable it's portable
water so you'd have to treat it some way
if you're going to have staff inside
there inside that building
have you allowed costumes for that
uh no
um once
if
the proposed area is um
approved uh we'll have to look further
at that but the
i'll then be talking to the euro club
and phoenix aviation or super ear now
um as to how they they coming from the
same water supply as what we would be
using
yeah i understand that i know what the
water supply is and it's just a small
pump in the ground uh up into the tanks
and it's not treated in any way so
so you think they'll would have to treat
it and there will be enough water there
to allow for washing down et cetera
for all the dog pounds and we believe so
yes
okay um
we would be able to fill a tank the same
as what the is behind the euro club so
there's uh
it could be 10 000 liters in storage at
any time
yeah but it's not so you'd have to have
consideration for the staff about uh the
health and safety aspects of the
non-drinking water inside there yes
congratulations neil good job well done
thank you
brett um john nicki you've still got
your hands up are
you you think thank you worship look and
a great good good work neil but i i
guess you know when i see a 50-year
facility going in place
um
you know there is there's a change in
this and and gore's property market
there's a there's a change in people's
wealth nationwide in terms of amenity
we've got to say one one of our key
assets for this district is our airport
and i'm just wondering if we're taking a
a long term view or a short short-term
view here on its location personally if
there's some form of gateway to gore by
way of the aircraft
and we've got a dog pound there it
doesn't fly with me
i i i think it's great work but i don't
think we've got a long-term long-term
view on the solution i could be wrong
but look there's there's residential
um
units springing up on airfields around
the country um
i think the
not that we're talking disposal but i
think the asset disposal working party
should have a little bit of a think
about this location before we
give it the absolute thumbs up
and i suppose just one question i had is
has the landfill site being considered
in terms of
a industrial area that isn't isn't
surrounded by residential and isn't that
popular to visit is locked
has has uh facilities is flood prone but
i guess so is the existing area but yeah
definitely just
i i think we could live to regret
putting the dog pound here maybe 25
years time could be wrong
yeah like yeah okay i understand exactly
the concerns that that you raise
brett
and
i guess that was really behind the
questioning of the of the planning group
had they thought about this
going forward
neil do you want to just make any
comments with regard to the comments
that brett's made and particularly
around
the transfer station site
yes three workshops the
landfill would be unsuitable mainly
because the ground stability
is the biggest problem there's also
quite a bit of residential
toronto street etc so you're not getting
away from
the residential area as such
um i've had quite a bit of discussion
with the euro club um members that i've
spoken to and in regards
that their clubhouse is at the um
western end of the
complex there along jubilee eve
and they're quite happy in regards to
that and even put an accommodation
facilities with a hanger
on that area but they cannot see an
issue with the
what could be regarded as a noise
problem with with the pound
so in the long term the air club are
looking forward
basically to something else being on
that premises
and having a bit more relationship with
the
core district council but they cannot
see an issue that moving forward
um that would hinder them
and as you say the
gateway airport
thank you
okay councillors
thank you worship i just got one
question uh the cost
i don't see in the report uh is it uh
the same amount that we uh passed or is
it going to be a substantial amount of
more it will be more substantial
uh what's the meaning of substantial
or any anything anything over a hundred
dollars is substantial to some
ratepayers we'll be substantially
okay uh are we going to get are we going
to be finished report um your worship on
regards of the cost fact for this
i would imagine there'll be more
information come to council is that
right neil
uh if you wish yes
if there's a change to the specification
um you know is that what's driving the
cost
uh one thing is that we have not been
able to secure the the building as such
the building was ordered over a year ago
and it has not yet been delivered
because we've been postponing it
so there we cannot say that they are
going to be able to
deliver that on site at the specified
price that we received at the beginning
of this year
so we have to go down that track also
there will be more
footing
needs to be put in for the foundations
of the building
um on that site and there will have to
be some more security fencing added and
if we had stayed down the ox station
pond
it sound it does sound like a good
alternative although
bearing in mind there could be some
long-term challenges
but
there probably is going to be a cost and
i don't think we're in a position to
know what that cost is is currently
because we don't have a confirmed price
from the
construction
so john did you want to raise the point
and then don't
no no i'm all right yeah okay
right don't
yeah thanks your worship i i can't
actually uh
vote for this recommendation because
as neville's just pointed out we don't
know what the final cost going to be now
the cost we thought was quite was
reasonably high
for uh the doll pound being put in where
it is or in that area
um
and also um
council heist has raised some very good
points also um
so
i um
unless there's more information come
back i think i would like to see
actually more information come back
before we can move on this i know
it's frustrating
especially with the
supply chain at the moment and costs
going up or whatever but um
when you
when
mr mia says substantial we don't know
whether it's going to be another 40
grand another 60 grand another 100
so
you've lost my vote on this one
thank you
all right so you returned it
well my alternative was i'd like some
more information uh maybe we we come
back with how much uh this nail it down
to within five grand of of what the cost
is going to be or um
we look at another solution but um
i mean it's
not taking anything away from mr mayor's
report great report but
the the fantastic question asked by
councillor phillips was what's the cost
and all of a sudden it could be
substantial now substantial we don't
know what substantial is so i i can't
vote on this so neil what sort of time
frame do you think
it's going to take to get a
figure on this one
uh
probably within the month
yes uh john
your hand up no
the worship if it helps the meeting um
what you could do is to approve in
principle deciding the dog pound at the
airport site areas website
and with a further report to be
furnished on the uh estim up and updated
it on updated estimates of cost to
construct that facility before final
approve is given
so do you think we could have that at
the council meeting in december
yes i'll get something
for you your worship
roman
thank you your worship i'd be happy to
move that with recommendation with those
few changes regarding the cost um i'd
also like to say it's a pity that the
staff have been put to this trouble um
because originally i noticed from the
report that the landowner was
quite happy with the dog pound being
cited there and then some reason has
done a 360. so well done neil for all
the work that you have done and
hopefully um the costs won't be
prohibited from going to the site
okay so um
stuart you've got your hand up
because he was never happy with it being
there that was wrong
i've spoken to him on a number of
occasions he never gave consent he
wanted to consider
the position and spoke with me about it
and suggested alternative sites down at
the
sewage treatment plant away from this
property but he was never happy with it
being there
i'm more than happy to uh second the
thing the only reason why i brought it
up about the finances is is a
for a case of transparency because at
the end of the day when um the ratepayer
asks
why did it cost so much we can say well
this is because we had to shift to this
and we saved in the long term we may say
money and
it's about transparency you worship but
i'm more than happy to second uh
so i'm not sure it's been moved um
you me i was moved by dennis was it not
a um councillor dixon was it not no so
do you want to move that
sorry worship councillor reed moved to
the motion sorry councillor sorry uh i'm
more than happy to see it you wish
okay
it's been moved and secreted uh moved by
council read secretary council phillips
that we have proven principle the
construction at
jubilee avenue
to be confirmed when we get a price at
our next council meeting which will be
in december
okay i'm going to put that motion all
those in favor please say i
against the motion is carried thank you
thank you councillors
um
right i think that might just about
bring us to the end
of the um
open
section of their agenda
so i'll move that
we move into committee
and